hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff uh i know you're wondering
how come there's another game between
paul charles morphy and the james
stanley kipping since we
uh only said there were two of them well
two of them were actual games over the
board and
this game is not uh well so to say over
the board because only keeping
is looking at the board whereas morphe
uh is holding a blindfold simultaneous
exhibition so this is uh one of the
games
morphy played again the third game and
final
against james stanley keeping morphy has
the white pieces
and uh again a few words for from
lawson's book
regarding this uh birmingham meeting as
everyone was
really eager to see if morphe would make
it in time if he would be able to play
in the tournament
and they even already paired him uh in
round one because they thought uh i mean
he's morphe of course he will come and
play
uh but he didn't he uh he was late on
purpose and he just wanted to to face
uh howard staunton so a a little bit
from the book so uh some of the
strongest participants
of this birmingham meeting uh staunton
folk beer lemental
uh saint aman uh owen bird and keeping
so those are some incredibly strong
gentlemen
and they say uh the the grand tournament
had started on august 24th
in the hope that morphe might arrive in
time to compete his name has
uh had been entered and paired with mr
smith
uh when morphe failed to arrive mr smith
was given the point
as there was uh an odd number of players
uh of the players worthy of special note
staunton love intel folk beer and saint
aman all won in the first round
so pairings for the second round brought
staunton against lomantal and imagine
this
uh lorenzo defeated staunton and kicked
him out of the tournament
uh whereas folk beer uh defeated saint
aman and
uh faced lointel in the finals and in
the finals
uh uh for the remainder of the
tournament to play was to be held in
london the grand tournament
being suspended the next day for
morphe's blindfold exhibition so
the grand final will have to wait for
morphe to complete his blindfold
exhibition
and then what happened as the conclusion
uh the long delayed final result of the
tournament it did not come until
september 23rd
when luventon by defeating folk beer won
first prize it was a fine recovery
considering that he had been uh
that he had suffered defeat by morphy
only three days
before the tournament the prize money
was uh greatly increased since morphy
had declined uh the 70 pounds that had
been
offered to him uh to come to england so
uh it does seem like hillary until gets
the last laugh maybe not the entire left
as he did not face morphy but he did the
win win a great tournament
here and i think even even if morphe
wasn't sure
if he was uh if he would defeat staunton
had they played i'm pretty sure he was
more than confident now
when he saw that he he lost to levanthal
uh but
like morphy said uh one game in the
tournament means nothing and this is
exactly why morphy wanted to face
lemental uh
in a series of games either the best of
10 best of 12 best of 16 whatever
but not like not like a game in the
tournament
so uh we're gonna get back to that and
see what happens in morphe's uh
relentless pursuit to face howard
staunton but now uh the third game
between paul charles morphy and james
stanley keeping uh morphe
being a blindfold so let's see what
happens uh morphe again opens with e4
sorry about that uh we have e5
uh knight to f3 knight to c6 and now
morphy doesn't go for bishop to c4
uh so unfortunately we'll not see
another evans gambit game between the
two of them
but rather goes for the scotch so d4 is
on the board with e captures on d4
and now rather than recapturing on d4
bishop to c4
and here keeping goes for bishop to c5
uh bishop to b4
is also uh kind of playable but it's a
very tricky tricky idea because after c3
black will capture and you can just
castle give up another pawn
and you're gonna get this position where
white give up a lot of pawns but his
bishop pair is uh really
fully operational and the black has to
be very careful here
but obviously keeping knows that morphy
is uh well versed in the secrets of the
scotch so he just goes bishop to c5
uh we have castles by morphe and
loventhal also
uh commented on this game he said that
uh c3 is playable here but c3 knight f6
uh goes into a very well uh known line
of the joko piano
that was known even back then so of
course morphe tries to avoid that
morphe castles here and now comes d6
again uh uh keeping shows that uh
he also knows a a lot of theory because
for example knight f6
e6 e5 attacking the knight and d5 go
into a well-known line of the italian
game the max lange attack
uh which also is uh avoided here so
d6 and now finally c3 by morphe
we have queen to c6 uh not really
interested in grabbing another pawn
and bishop to g5 now challenging the
queen queen g6 and only now morphy
captures on d4
c captures on d4 we have a small
capture fest here captures captures and
now queen captures on g5
and here morphy goes for f4 not worried
about
opening up this diagonal because uh he
can always play something like king to
h1 and
there there are no problems here uh here
we have queen to g6 by keeping and
now king to h1 now morphy and pinned and
the knight can finally move
uh and here uh the problem is you cannot
go for the pawn if you go for the pawn
then just rookie one wins the queen
so that's not happening so here keeping
went knight to h6
it's a bit of a mystery one knight to
the h6 instead of knight to f6 but
he probably thought morphy would uh
march forward with the e pawn so maybe
he wanted the f5 square for the knight
who knows
but okay uh here he played knight to h6
and it uh
probably confused morphy as you can see
i used this uh
quote by elemental himself above the
board the accuracy with which mr morphy
opens
his games when playing blindfold is
truly remarkable and this is
uh pretty much true for all the games
morphy played blindfold except for this
one
because here you have to be very careful
you should either go f5 or you should go
bishop to b5
check it kind of force black into
into hiding or something like that just
continue developing knight to c3
but the move morphe played it seems like
a reasonable move uh just taking away
the g4 square from
the from the knight so the knight cannot
go here cannot go here
but this actually loses the game for
morphe so
uh morphy missed it because he was
blindfolded but uh hopefully you are not
uh as you are watching a video and
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for keeping
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you have just
defeated paul charles murphy and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's bishop captures on h3 and this is
just a wonderful idea
because now queen captures on e4 will
come
with check and not accepting the bishop
is just
i mean you have you you don't have any
good moves here you're being uh
checkmate is being threatened and really
there's not
not at all anything you can play here so
morphe did capture the bishop
but now comes queen captures on e4 this
comes with check
and uh the uh keeping will just win win
back the piece so
uh morphy completely missed this idea
it's a two move combination but playing
blindfold it was enough for morphe to
miss it
so queen to f3 he immediately offers a
queen trade
uh and the knockouts queen captures on
d4 so the knight is recaptured
rook to e1 with check and now king to d7
so the black king is a bit loose but
white king is
complete his defenses are completely
busted so here
knight a3 defending the bishop here and
now just bishop captures an a3 removing
one of the defenders of the bishop on c4
so of course you cannot recapture but
first bishop to b5 check we have
c6 and now comes b captures on a3
morphe tries to trick keeping
into capturing the bishop here but then
just queen captures on b7 and it's all
over king has to move
and you lose the rook here because the
king has nowhere to go the rook
completely cuts off the king from the e
file
you would have to go back and now the
rook is undefended and that's just it or
you don't even have to play this you can
even play rook to c1
and it's checkmate whatever black plays
even if something like this then this is
checkmate
so morphe had an idea here however
keeping of course not interested in the
bishop on b5 just continued development
the rook h
to e8 uh we have rook eight to c one by
morphy
and now comes d5 now the queen no longer
has access to the b7 pawn
so morphy shifts it over to b3 queen to
b3
and now again can you capture the bishop
well if you capture it
then queen captures on b5 with check and
it's incredibly tricky again the rook
controls the entire e file
and king would have to be very very
careful of course you cannot go to
king to d8 then rook capture sunny it is
checkmate so you'd have to go king to d6
and then we just have rook captures
rook captures and queen captures and we
get this end game uh where
morphy would be up the exchange but uh
with with the king
so loose it's very hard to uh to
uh say that he would be able to do
something about it even queenie for
chuck just straight
trades the queens and black has more
pawns it would be
white would definitely be better here
but how how much better it's hard to say
so here instead after queen to b3 uh we
have uh
we don't have captures but rather king
to c7 so very
very precise play by keeping and
morphing continues with bishop to d3 now
the bishop can no longer stay there
we have rook to e3 sorry black rook to
e3
uh now with the double attack here and
now morphy trades rook to e3
queen captures on e3 and now rook to b1
morphe goes after the b7 pawn
and now just queen captures an h3 there
wasn't anything
morphy could have done about this so
king the g1 and now while you can
immediately
continue harassing the white king even
goku knights the g4
uh keeping uh sees no reason to allow
queen captures on b7 so he plays b6
and now uh rook to e1 by morphe hoping
to
uh to make some sort of a nice rook lift
here but just rook
queen g3 uh the king has to defend the
rook otherwise you're gonna lose the
rook so king f1
now queen captures on f4 with check king
g2
and now queen to g5 with check king f1
and now
knight the g4 uh not much to do for
white here the e7 square is now covered
by the queen so morphy goes rookie too
but now knight the e3 check and it was
in this position that paul morphy
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done you
can give up the rook but then you're
just in a terrible position down
material
or you could continue with king f2 but
other than just rook to e8 and
again bla white has no moves here
whatever you play let's say you
play anything uh is just a very nice
king hunt queen h4
check king of three queen h3 checking f2
now we're gonna go queen f1 check
and now the rook is lost king g3 queen
captures on e2
and so on uh so after knight to
morphe resigned and uh an excellent
victory for james stanley
keeping uh who was able to get one
victory uh against paul charles murphy
uh
uh albeit a blindfold one but still uh
you know
any victory against uh paul morphy is a
great victory and he probably
uh you know uh told the story of this
great victory to everyone
like uh uh for for for his entire life
i mean who who wouldn't uh so yeah this
is one of the games uh from
morphy's uh blindfold exhibition um i'm
gonna try and look for some other ones
maybe they're interesting if they are
we're gonna show them if not we are
continuing
morphy's pursuit to face howard stanton
over the board in a series of games
and prove that he is not only the finest
uh
chess player in america but also in
europe and of course uh
by that definition in those days the
entire world
so yeah that's uh the game i do hope you
guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank jonathan
paul madrid
manfred sikenberger uh solomon yakubu
thomas blondel and jeremy wade for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and if you don't know
the first link in the description below
starts the morphe saga
from scratch so if you're new to the
channel you can also check that out as
well
see you soon